hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights of [ __ ]
boys I got a very special surprise to
show you that I did while I was grinding
off in the off hours that you didn't see
me doing me - very impressive what I was
doing trying to beat the level five hats
when I'm not ready to beat him but I did
it and I got the I won't show you this
first boy you can probably already see
it but hang on I need to pour my shat
need to pour my shat P here's to you and
me together forever all seven-and-a-half
billion of you okay here we go
oh not down my windpipe this dub that's
good okay so I got I set out to get the
key shards because I thought I could
because the hats are very basic enemy so
if I could just luck out and have them
miss me cuz they were only in like pairs
of two I couldn't get one by itself but
I got the Omega key along with all five
key parts hoping there is just five key
parts because there's only five power
levels soon as she is so now I might be
able to go here okay
well toodaloo I don't know how to do it
I have them what do I do with it
I damn it god damn it okay oh I don't
know what opposed to do now I have I
have all of them I went out of my way to
do that I thought I was doing good I
didn't even level all pose it ah son of
a [ __ ] I [ __ ] how do I do this how do I
do this gotta be a way to do maybe I can
like turn them into Balloon Boy but
probably only like the correct blue boy
that I could turn them in do but I don't
know there's got to be what I know I
want that dragon dildo so badly I want
it climb its gonna make me so strong
congratulations can you get me a dragon
build Ripper okay so basically oops I
meant to save there cuz this might crash
a game like
how's it happen often but crashing the
game only happens when you're coming out
of a battle I didn't save me don't don't
grass on me okay we're good okay so
since like the only thing I have to do
right now is farm a bit because I need
to level up a lot more before I'm able
to fight uh who's next like I don't even
know I guess Foxy's next I think foxy
was 30 I believe anyway so what I'm
doing is I'm just farming up for a bit
and the only reason I'm not fighting
level fours is because these level
threes are really easy and I mean I can
kill a lot of them I can gillman one hit
most of the time and they give good
number of XP and a lot of tokens so it's
like what other do I have to do besides
farm so considering that I just decided
ah queue for a little bit I wanted to
talk about my trip to New York basically
because I glanced over it because not a
lot of people like understand why I was
invited out to New York and it's
actually a really cool thing on youtubes
part where they brought a bunch of
youtubers out to New York for creator
summit just like talk to you know highly
influential creators and I was like why
am I here just because I was in among
all these really cool youtubers and
whatnot I was talking to them and I was
meeting them noses like wow like you're
like you and I'm like me and you're like
wow and I'm like okay this is like it
was bizarre because but you know I
almost didn't go to the thing because I
was very busy or I'm I'm always very
busy but it was just like a unique
experience because I was able to
actually meet all these people and also
I felt like appreciated by YouTube which
if you know like my history I have a I
have a beef with YouTube because they
canceled my adsense account on my vers
first YouTube channel and I had to give
up that YouTube channel and that's why
my channel's name markipliergame not
margul I I think I discussed this in
like one of the other five nights of
fuckboys but it was really cool to see
because I finally got to talk to people
at YouTube and and not many people know
that for youtubers like we don't have a
direct line with YouTube you would think
we would but we do not have a direct
line of youtube or at least we didn't
anymore and now I actually do which is
kind of really cool so now it was one of
those things that made me feel like
YouTube is becoming a bigger thing than
what it once was
which is both good and bad at the same
time like it's scary to think that it's
it like YouTube is taking itself more
seriously but also taking its creators
more seriously that's a good thing
that's a good thing because I feel like
there's a lot of creators out there who
are extremely talented and need to be
taken seriously and need to be given a
lot of respect and given a lot of more
potential to release their creativity
not saying me I got I got my own stuff
I'm totally fine but also it's like you
know it's a community it's not just a
community for you guys out there
watching I mean it is but I mean it's
not just that it's also a community for
the youtubers that make these videos
like I was honored because I'm a fan of
like a lot of the people that I met out
there and I'm a fan of them because I've
been watching them forever I'm like one
of you but I'm also like one of them in
considering that I love YouTube I love
everything about you
that's what makes YouTube so great
anyone can do anything and they can just
do what they want to do
oh also I forgot to mention um there was
this uh there was this item that I
equipped that I got out of the thing
called lucky soda I didn't read what it
was but it makes items drop more often
which is good because then I can get
things like this HP boost that can
permanently upgrade my HP which is good
because that is like better than
leveling in a lot of cases so anyway
that was all I had to say about them
below saying about YouTube is it
it's his community among youtubers to
like youtubers get together and
youtubers are people to like everyone's
just people like if more people realize
that people were just people and then
the differences that break society down
aren't that big in the first place and
you shouldn't be worried about the
[ __ ] of your daily life and what
makes you angry
as opposed to what makes you happy the
world would be a better place but you
know life lessons optimism and you know
idealism I think is what I call but I
it's whatever but I mean I I digress a
lot from talking about my trip to New
York but it was like New York is awesome
because I Love New York TV for first
place but this event in New York was
awesome because it solidified the fact
that anyone can do whatever they want
and that's what I try to tell you guys
because I'm not special you know I'm not
special
I'm a have a good voice but there's a
lot of people that have better voices an
idea that were you know
you know not doing what they want to do
it's like everyone is potential like
everyone has the their own special
ability even if you don't think you have
one that means you haven't found it yet
like you haven't tried enough new things
to get to the point where you have found
exactly what you want and what you're
gonna do and what's gonna make you stand
out in the world like you can find it
you just have to try new things and
that's why like you have to not be
afraid of exploring the possibilities
out there and exploring what can be done
you just have to reach out and try new
things and like with this YouTube trip
that's what I want to do I want to try
new things I want to do so many new
things with YouTube that's why I talked
about you know with Jack about pursuing
music and like because it's always been
something that's on my mind and it's
something that I want to do and I really
just want to do it like I want to do it
so I'm gonna do that like that's why you
know I've been working very hard like
last night I was up and go 6:00 in the
morning working on videos I slept plenty
after that but I was just up late
because I had to get work done because I
have to like have to make sure there's
enough time for me to do it and that
means preparing videos beforehand and
not saying this isn't one of them I'm
recording a lot in a row but that's
because I have to hey awesome
like oh oh play this game okay I'm level
25 is that good enough is it good enough
is it good enough I don't know if it's
good enough is it gonna be gonna am I
just gonna die I've been getting a lot
of HP boosts Wow whatever all far more
but either way what I'll finish up by
just saying you know at the end of the
day if more people realize that everyone
around them are more similar to them
than they know then the world would be a
much happier place so I'm gonna keep
farming a little bit more but that's one
of them
let me know what you think of what I'm
saying the gobber's book cuz obviously
I'm starting to get a little drunk
and maybe what I'm saying is it make
sense I'm obviously jumping from topic
to topic and not keeping a coherent line
of thought but like that be right back
alright so I'm gonna go in the portal
and see what's what I mean oh wait hey I
need to say before I do this uh uh okay
just because I want to see what is up
with this because if like if it's just
gonna be a big bear I need to know
whether or not I need to level up a
whole lot more or if I'm eventually
gonna be able to do it Molesey this is
much well isn't that all bear rude skill
you I let you jack off on the blanket
under under Bowl yeah so soothing
oh that foxy [ __ ] how you doing
okay so what do you got big boy what
could you possibly do to me that's going
to be so horrible probably bad stuff
okay now let me try to stun ya
was please tell me that was an attack
that just brought me down to one health
and it was specifically designed like
that to make me scared and not want to
continue because if that was the case
then we don't have a problem and I can
continue because I'll actually heal like
I should I should get my agility up
first so that I go first I need to get
my agility up so that I get my first
turn in because otherwise I'm gonna be
[ __ ] yeah
crap come on Jesus dammit I know I can
beat this guy he's not actually hitting
me that hard it's just that his attack
that gets me all the way down to one
health I just need to stun him if I can
stun him I'm good to be honest I thought
that large pizzas would heal more than
600 I mean it's not enough
I need more baby I need more oh that's
right okay maybe all that damage being
taken is activating my special abilities
and I'm gonna be able to do what I need
to do to be able to do that obviously
the agility doesn't matter it doesn't
let me go for us first anyway but if I
can keep them off balance I'll be good
haven't stunned him yet but if I do this
twice while I'm waiting for myself to be
under stunt I should be oh [ __ ] well
that's okay because then I use these
immediately and I'm back up to a good
point and then he did enough damage such
that I am in a decent place so let me
just do that whoa whoa Wham
yeah
yeah he did that I knew he's gonna do
that so Pizza Pizza and now I have
enough to do a strong combo which is
good right and then immediately after
that use a pizza dos on me oh come on oh
come on well come on that's such
[ __ ] oh you [ __ ] bastard [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] me
Kim oh come on
and and a half half is good not good
enough cuz I couldn't stun him once pass
and ball whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
yet hundred twenty six yeah I did it I
did it yeah okay I did it okay
so damn the guy fellas overkill I'm
really lucky that backup bass can really
come in handy
well all I did was I was dying over and
over again I was just trying to back up
a show over and over again until it
finally worked
whew okay did it good I did it I'm happy
oh man I probably wasn't even supposed
to do this what I'm gonna have to do is
I'm gonna have to level up like a lot
before I'm able to do what I need to do
unless I can somehow find the Dargan
doll though I [ __ ] de make ya have my
beanie is not behaving my hair wants to
creep out the floof is taking over
alright what I'm gonna do Phantom lunge
good I can finally lunge Oh what is that
what is that what what hair is that I
don't know the floof it's like reaching
out its fluffy tentacle underneath my
beanie he does not want to be contained
okay one of the locks why am i oh this
is where Foxy's was I didn't know this I
didn't know that at all
oh wait hang on let me see what phantom
lunge Oh incredibly slight chance of
dropping the darkest HP to one well
that's great that's slightly low Eggman
okay all right I mean that's good I
guess but not really what I need so
okay so either way I'm gonna read this
thing that I got see what it is I don't
know what this is trying to tell me oh
yes let's do this I don't have much time
to write today after further
investigation I have unearthed more
knowledge about the first incarnation of
the elusive traveller the temporal
manipulation machine that they possessed
was used by the immortal foes strangely
however there is a glaring hole that
confuses the entire discovery this party
originated from the future of the third
timeline if they were no different to
the first a second this crown trust with
their incarnation of the traveler being
dead the third timeline progresses much
like the first and second including some
of the travelers initial plans what
could this mean I'm going to continue my
research and see what I find next I have
a hunch about this but I'm not positive
the professor this is actually
interesting like I don't know what these
means what is this all about why is this
here what does it mean or did I also get
any other items from I don't think so
how do I open this chest I want it open
I know it's locked open it damn it
you're gonna get bashed in the ground
cuz I got nothing better to do with my
life give me something good nope you
give me nothing okay so either way that
is all the time I have for this episode
here thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for joining me for
another fun adventure at five nights at
[ __ ] boys I really don't know how long
except it's gonna be a lot of it was
just kind of of the camera stuff oh
whatever
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see
Rochelle raunchy
one one one one